I want to do a quick primer on
refraction and our focus here is going
to be on seismic waves but the
principles how things refract when they
go from a fast to a slow medium or a
slow to a fast medium it's actually the
same as you would see when you're doing
when you're studying light waves or
actually any type of wave so let's think
about it a little bit so let's say I
have a slow a slow medium right over
here and let's say I have a fast medium
right over here and let's say just for
the so that we can travel through both
solid and liquid let's think about maybe
P waves and a slow medium could be maybe
some type of liquid in our fast way and
our fast medium could be some type of
solid so let me draw the boundary right
over here and let's say so if I have
something that goes that cut o P wave a
P wave let's say it's going through the
water and it's going right perpendicular
to the boundary it will then just
continue to travel in the faster medium
in the same direction if it's going
right if it goes right at the boundary
if it goes right at the boundary and
it'll just travel faster in the faster
medium and that's because that faster
medium is going to be more dense and the
molecules are going to bump into each
other faster in the same amount of time
more molecules kind of a chain reaction
is going to be able to travel further
because they're more closely packed and
they rebound faster than it would in the
slow medium so that's obviously no
refraction is going on it has not been
deflected and just as a bit of a
reminder in general refraction is when a
wave gets it deflected reflection is
when it bounces back or refraction is
when it gets deflected a little bit let
me just make that clear so if I have
some type of boundary here and I have a
wave that bounces off that's a
reflection but if the wave goes through
the boundary and just gets bent a little
bit its direction changes that is a
refraction and that's what we're talking
about so clearly so far this P wave has
not been refracted but if this P wave
comes in at an angle so let's make this
P wave come in at an angle what's going
to happen is and the way you should
think about it it's it's the easiest way
to think about which direction will be
refracted or at least the way I think
about it is literally I imagine some
type of vehicle some type of vehicle
with wheels on it so this is the top
view of my vehicle
so if I have some type of vehicle and
the wheels will be able to move slowly
in this medium you can kind of view it
it's kind of on mud so it doesn't get
good traction and then the fast medium
maybe it's a road so it gets a good
traction it can move faster so what's
gonna happen when the vehicle gets to
the boundary
well this bottom right wheel is going to
go on the fast medium before any of the
other wheels do so it's going to get the
traction first these wheels on the left
side of the vehicle these wheels right
here these are still going to be stuck
in the mud so what's gonna happen is
this wheel right over here is moving
faster so it's essentially going to be
able to turn the vehicle these guys are
still stuck in the mud and so you fast
forward a little bit the direction of
the vehicle will change and so the
vehicle will now move in a direction
something like this the same thing would
happen in a wave if the p-wave is
approaching the boundary like this and
something analogous to this is happening
at the molecular level you can kind of
view it as even billiard balls and maybe
you know they're kind of hitting each
other well I won't go into that because
that can kind of get a little confusing
depending on the different cases and the
different boundaries but this is the
easiest way to think about in which
direction it will refract and hopefully
it makes a little bit of intuitive sense
and so when you go from a slow to a fast
medium our P wave would kind of its
angle would accentuate in that direction
if you went from if you went from the
fast medium to the slow medium once
again you can just go through the same
thought experiment so let's say you have
our wave coming in like that draw the
car visualize the car here
visualize the car right here and you say
well look this tire is gonna get stuck
in the mud because now we're going from
this it was on the road now this top
left this top tire right over here is
get stuck in the mud first so it's going
to be moving slower so these tires are
gonna be able to move faster so the
vehicle is going to turn so you'll be
refracted in a direction like that when
you're going from the fast of the slow
medium so that's just a primer on
refraction generally now let's think
about what would happen when sound waves
are traveling through the earth and this
will help inform us of essentially how
do we figure out what the actual
structure of the earth is so if the
earth was just made up of some uniform
material and you had you had an
earthquake right here
on earth maybe a little bit below the
surface so like you know it's in the
it's happening in the crust but a little
bit below the surface of the earth if
earth was of uniform density if it was
all the same material how would those
let's just think about the p-waves how
it cuz P waves can travel in anything
let's think about how those P waves
would travel well they were just going
straight lines there's nothing that
would refract the P waves it would just
go in straight lines radially outward
radially outward from where the
earthquake occurred from where the
earthquake occurred now at a first
approximation we know that as we go
deeper and deeper into earth there's
more and more rock above that the weight
of that rock is kind of compressing the
rock below it so you get higher and
higher pressures and higher and higher
densities so how would so this is a
uniform earth this is a uniform but
let's imagine an earth that's made up of
uniform material that's all solid a
completely solid earth but one where the
density is constantly increasing as you
go down so let's just think about it
and before we go into the continuous
case because we're talking about the
density as you go deeper it's it's it's
just getting continuously more dense
let's think about the discrete case
where we have we have the least dense
layer so let me draw it right over here
so let's say this is the surface of the
earth and this is least dense least
dense then let's say you have another
layer over here that is more dense so
this is more dense more dense let's say
you have another layer that's even more
dense so you have another layer over
here that's even even more more dense
and then let's do one more layer let's
let's do this layer here that this is
the densest layer densest so in general
in general your P wave your seismic wave
is going to travel faster and denser
materials so it's going to travel the
fastest here then here then here it's
gonna travel the slowest and the solis
dense material so if you're coming in at
an angle if you're coming in at an angle
let's think about what's going to happen
so let's say you have your P wave coming
in at an angle like this so it's going
straight through the least dense
material what's gonna happen when it
goes into the let me do a
slightly shallower angle so let's say
it's like that what's gonna happen when
it goes into the more dense material so
once again let's imagine our little car
so this tire is going to be able to go
faster before the tires on the other
side so the car is going to be deflected
to the left to the down left so now it's
going to travel like this so it's now
going to travel something like this now
what's gonna happen at this boundary
once again imagine the car this tire
right here is going to be able to travel
faster before the other tire so it'll be
deflected even more in that direction
then we go and go to the densest
material once again the tires on kind of
the bottom side when we look at it this
we're gonna be able to get move faster
before the other tire so we're gonna get
deflected even more so you see as you go
from least dense material to more dense
mature you're kind of curving outward so
if this was continuous if you had a
continuous kind of a continuous
structure where as you go down it just
gets more and more dense as you go so
this is less less dense and then it just
continuously it continuously gets more
dense so this is the most dense down
here how would the refraction look well
then it would just be a continuous curve
it would look like this your your P wave
would constantly be refracted out like
that it would curve outwards so if we if
earth so this was a simplest example
where earth is uniform and you know
that's pretty easy to dismiss that you
know obviously things will get denser
because of more pressure down so let's
say we assume another thing we have a
uniform earth in terms of composition
but let's say it gets denser so denser
at the center then how would the p-waves
travel then how would the p-waves travel
or how would any seismic waves travel
well then if you have your earthquake
right over here the ones that are going
straight down still would go straight
down because we know that we won't get
refracted if we're kind of going
perpendicular to the to the change in
medium or the change in boundaries but
things that are coming at a slight angle
as they get deeper they're gonna get
deflected more and more and more and
they're going to be refracted outward
just like we saw in this example here if
they go on this angle is going to be
refracted outward like that if they go
here they're gonna be refracted outward
like that they're gonna be refracted
outward like that
if you're here you're going to be
refracted outward like that if you're
here you're going to be refracted
outward like that this now what we're
going to do in the next few videos is
use what we just learned about
refraction in the case of seismic waves
and hopefully we learned it in this
video and how it would refract as we're
going through ever-increasing denser
material we're going to use that that
information to essentially try to figure
out the composition of the earth based
on based on what we've actually observed